avec nous pierre karl péladeau président
et chef de la direction de quebecor
monsieur péladeau bonsoir on va recevoir
vous y serez mercredi est-ce que vous
pouvez pas ce que les gens attendent
toujours la même chanson quand on parle
de la crise dans les médias les revenus
ont chuté sur une évidence les géants du
web prennent leur part de ça sans payer
un sou là on est rendu à la journée et
aux journées des solutions pour vous
expliquer avez-vous vous qu'est ce que
vous allez venir proposé mercredi que
devrait faire le gouvernement legault je
me permettrai quand même de garder un
peu de respect pour les parlementaires
est donc entre guillemets la primeur
pour celui ci lorsque nous allons nous
présenter mercredi à l'assemblée
nationale en commission parlementaire
mais j'aimerais parce que vous avez eu
donc la gentillesse de m'inviter
j'écoute la bulletin avec vous et puis
j'ai vu monsieur trudeau donc enfin
méthode la situation je trouve que
encore une fois nous sommes devant
l'absence de leadership l'absence de
leadership d'un premier ministre du
canada qui aurait dû prendre déjà depuis
un certain temps des mesures appropriées
donc depuis combien d'années déjà que
nous souhaitons que les géants du web
dont notamment netflix bon lors de ma
part une taxe spéciale on simplement
donc la tps taxe sur laquelle tous les
produits et services au canada vous
voudriez qu'ils fassent que monsieur
macron a fait en france exactement
risque c'est ce que j'allais dire donc
les fameux gaffard donc n'essayez pas de
ça vient pas de ça c'est pas sorti d'un
chapeau
si on suit le moindrement à un petit peu
particulièrement évidemment l'actualité
en europe la question de la taxation
c'est pas lui mais la semaine dernière
c'est un sujet que les parlementaires
européens ont soulevé depuis un très
grand nombre d'années pourquoi le
premier ministre donne s'inspire pas
justement de ce qui est fait et s'allie
avec également aussi les européens pour
faire en sorte qu'on a un régime de
taxation équitable un régime de taxation
qui vont être équivalents ce qui
s'applique aux autres entreprises ici
canadien il avait couvert vol soldats à
le dire beaucoup de gens disent et
incontournable il faut que les
conditions s'appliquent pour tous les
joueurs mais à côté de ça est ce que le
gouvernement doit développer une
politique publique
pour aider directement les journaux les
médias
chose certaine nous avons dénoncé
effectivement les particulière qui
avaient été apportées à un seul groupe
le groupe capital médias par philippe
couillard son gouvernement dix millions
qui ont disparu comme ça en famille
relativement rapidement soit disant pour
gérer une transition numérique sa
transition numérique tous les journaux
l'ont fait ici de l'onp au fait pourquoi
les contribuables paierait pour
malheureusement les erreurs qui ont été
plus je sais que l'on va me dire oui
mais séjournera appartenait à part
pourquoi on a été graisser journal à
l'intérieur d'un plus grand ensemble qui
s'appelait cyberpresse mais c'est la
presse qui a instauré la gratuité c'est
guy crevier qui a décidé dorénavant donc
de mettre tout ce gratuitement sur
internet à une erreur mais c'est une
grave erreur parce défense eiffel où est
la suite des choses
parce que laisser couler tout le monde
il ne resterait en presse écrite que
vous jouez régulation c'est qu'on doit
se poser comme contribuable ce cas on va
payer les erreurs des des organisations
qui ont été faites dans le passé parce
que c'est trop facile comme ici on fait
pas ça c'est quoi
que vous soyez seul dans le domaine des
gens dont moi
nous avons eu la semaine dernière je
suis absent vous revenez de vacances
mais j'attends du oui oui vous m'avez
entendu donc nous allons j'ai fait une
proposition
une proposition qui faisant en sorte
parce qu'on ne peut plus vivre de la
façon dont on vivait intérieurement
les changements sont comme passée par là
et d'ailleurs nous avons pris des
mesures nécessaires chic à une certaine
époque ça a été très mal vu mais
aujourd'hui il existe une rentabilité
dans les journaux de quebecor pourquoi
parce que les décisions difficiles ont
dû être prises et nous les avons prions
pour que les gens nous suivent bien vous
êtes moi je suis prêt à racheter capital
médias jean n'est pas dangereux c'est un
autre portrait parce que là dorénavant
le gouvernement a décidé donc de faire
appel aux tribunaux et les mentionné à
plusieurs reprises nous avons perdu le
contrôle nous avons souhaité nous avions
souhaité mettre en place une proposition
qui allait faire en sorte justement
d'assurer la pérennité à vous
vous vouliez acheter captain médias en
plaidant que dans ce domaine là ça prend
une grande concentration s'aperçoivent à
votre théorie là votre idée ça prend je
les mentionnaient donc une optimisation
et la mise en place d' économie
d'échelle c'est vrai pour toutes les
industries je vois pas pourquoi parce
que c'est vrai la presse la presse
écrite ou les médias
mais c'est aussi une industrie le fait
qu'on transporte de l'information
lorsque fondante ou qu'on arcueil et que
la livre c'est aussi tout un phénomène
industriel particulièrement pour la
presse écrite et des imprimeries
il ya de la distribution donc tout ça
doit également faire l'objet d'une
optimisation et si vous n'êtes pas en
mesure de pouvoir procurer des économies
d'échelle et c'est là aussi où les
solutions qui sont cinq sont proposées
aujourd'hui un crédit d'impôt c'est
humain est-ce que ces crédits d'impôt
lors vont pouvoir permettre
véritablement de faire en sorte que ces
publications ne devienne rentable
moi j'en doute j'en doute parce qu'un va
falloir effectivement mettre en place et
surtout et avant tout justement ce que
je viens de parler
les économies d'échelle et
l'optimisation des dépenses est comme ça
toutes les industries sont sont logés à
la même enseigne comme si on vous avait
dit très bien puis on s'entend puis
acheté tout ça admettons le soleil de
québec aurait duré une année ou deux
pour leur ai fermé par exemple deux
journaux par les déficiences bon je n'ai
que le soleil et le journal de québec
ont leur place
maintenant est-ce qu'on est en mesure de
pouvoir faire en sorte d'optimiser le
plus efficacement possible de maintenir
la rentabilité des deux journaux je
pense que c'était possible dans un
avenir immédiat maintenant est ce qu'on
est capable de prendre des garanties à
jamais indéniablement je pense que la
réponse est non mais dans les
circonstances qui sont celles qui
existent aujourd'hui j'ai tendance à
penser qu'effectivement et je leur ai
souhaité aussi que le soleil demeure
mais c'est pas ça m'amène à l'autre
suggère transat bon j'avais perdu votre
paris vendredi
effectivement une autorité politique
vaudois vont se pencher sur cette
question le ministre garde on va décider
si oui ou non ce que j'avais dans
l'intérêt public
jarry
ce que je vais vous dire c'est que dans
le domaine des journaux et des médias
s'est passé d'avoir une concurrente aux
carmes est d'avoir des joueurs en vie
qui font de l'argent et qui
compétitionne pour la démocratie
si le c'est le scénario qui idéal non
oui c'est l'idéal nous avez raison mais
ainsi ce scénario là n'est pas réaliste
il n'existe pas quelle est la solution
des problèmes ou des ovaires bien
quelles vont être les acheteurs qui vont
se présenter pour acheter les journaux
cette bande jaune de je leur dis bonne
chance parce qu'effectivement si ça
prend de la quincaillerie derrière l'eau
donc dans l'autre domaine de l'aviation
vous dites l'absence de concurrence là
ça peut faire mal libyens peuvent monter
dans le cas d'air transat qui a été
acheté par air canada
il vous reste un espoir théorique c'est
le bureau de la concurrence
il ya eu deux je pense donc peut-être
que donc les politiciens comme
d'habitude on vouloir jouer à ponce
pilate s'en laver les mains
mais marc garneau a devant lui donc le
devoir de se pencher sur cette question
là le ministre des transports fédéral
d'autoriser la transaction et de
l'autoriser en fonction de ce que il
considéré l'intérêt public est-ce que
c'est d'intérêt public que de voir donc
une entreprise contrôlée
plus de 60% des routes transatlantiques
est-ce que c'est d'intérêt public de
voir une entreprise contrôlée plus de
40% sur les destinations soleil
je pense que ça va être menace de se
poser la question en ce qui me concerne
la réponse n'a paraît assez évident que
60%
c'est énorme et ensuite effectivement le
bureau de la concurrence sur les mêmes
questions va devoir également aussi
répondre à ces questions étaient déçus
par le gouvernement le go là dessus vous
l'avez écrit abondamment écoutez c'est
parce que j'ai entendu le ministre a
encore vendredi dernier je suis
québécois le siège social d'air transat
de vaud disparaître et c'est normal
moi si j'étais un pdg d'air canada je
ferai la même chose que lui pourquoi
beaucoup m'ont tous les commentateurs
l'ont dit pourquoi avoir deux vestes les
enfants juridique de s'y est faux de ça
n'a pas de sens économique
alors qu'on a c'est de nous baratiner
qu'on a c'est de dire l' inverse et j'ai
lu évidemment donc la correspondance de
quelle énorme une escuse samedi dans les
journaux mais yves boisvert de la presse
dit qu' il ne faut pas croire aux
promesses d'air canada 19 du même nom
mais ce cas on fait toujours des blagues
des fois t'es la presse en dur oui mais
très bon oeil a volé la vedette
c'est le titre de l'article ce matin
dans ce rassemblement militant avec le
bloc québécois est ce que vous préparez
votre entrée au parti qu est ce que
c'est quelque chose qui est encore
existant dans votre tête lorsque vous
jonglez que cette possibilité je pense
que tout le monde tous les québécois et
les québécoises connaissent ma passion
pour l'économie québécoise connaissent
ma passion pour la protection des
intérêts économiques des québécois et
des québécoises et françois blanchet m
inviter donc à participer à la rencontre
d'hier
j'y suis allé justement sur ces
questions là est essentiellement mon
discours mon intervention
c'est s'est concentré sur ces questions
là et je persiste à penser encore une
fois qu'une nation va s'enrichir
seulement et seulement si effectivement
est en mesure de se développer qu'on est
mené pour réaliser ces objectifs là que
vous avez est ce que vous pensez encore
que ça passe par un engagement actif en
policier moi vous savez lorsqu'on m'a
fait une tribune puis on m'offre
effectivement aussi en même temps
d'aller parler d'économie québécoise
comme je le fais avec vous mais je n'ai
toujours je ne refuse pas cette
invitation au contraire je les accepte
et je pense parce que c'est une intime
conviction encore une fois que défendre
les intérêts économiques du québec c'est
défendre la liberté politique
ces dépassements mais vous répondez pas
à la question vous savez est-ce que vous
jonglez encore avec l'idée de vous
présenter comme celle ci par là lol je
ne sais pas encore mais parce que vous
l'avez dit enregistrer des équipements
non j'ai malheureusement dû quitter la
politique
son geste en retour moi je suis pdg de
quebecor à l'heure actuelle je fais mon
travail et puis en même temps aussi le
bénéfice d'avoir parce que donc on a
quand même relativement bien réussi ici
a des occasions qui se présentent comme
celle qui s'est présentée pour taxes
locaux
j'essaie de les réaliser effectivement
saint-élie corps il luttait air transat
encore aujourd'hui je pense et je les
mentionnaient chaleur ce dossier n'est
pas terminée et on verra bien par la
suite avec le groupe capital médias la
suite des choses pires qu'en perdre on
suit votre intervention merkel
10 à québec ce à cette commission
parlementaire sur l'avenir des médias
merci d'être merci aux emprunts merci